MALE SPEAKER: Please
welcome Heidi Lee.
[APPLAUSE]
HEIDI LEE: Thanks, guys.
So I'm a hat designer.
And I've been fortunate enough
to have a lot of success
and recognition over the years.
Here are a few of my
hats, as you can see.
And they were showcased at
Silicon Valley Fashion Week
yesterday.
And I wanted to
actually bring them
to you, so that you could see
them in person on real people.
And thankfully,
these lovely women
have been able to
volunteer for me today.
As you can see, they're
pretty eye-catching.
But behind that, there's a
lot of thought and process
that goes behind
each of my stories.
And each of them have
a narrative and story
within their own right.
And I'd like to
share them with you.
The first hat here is
the Cocktail Parasol hat.
And it's 3D-printed,
laser-centered nylon.
And it's flexible,
as you can see.
And it was based
on Karakasa-Obake.
Which is a legend that dates
back, like, hundreds of years
ago in Japanese folklore,
where parasols gained souls
after 100 years.
So I decided to electrocute
the Karakasa-Obake.
And what remains is the boning,
or the architecture of decay.
And that's the origin
story behind this hat.
And this hat garnered
a letter of recognition
from Harold Koda, the curator
in charge of the Met Museum
and the Costume Institute, which
is now called the Anna Wintour
Costume Center.
And that happened in 2012.
And I could say that
was about the same time
when I really started to get
more serious about endeavoring
in making more innovative
and creative pieces as a hat
designer.
OK, thank you.
You can stay here.
This is the Vortex hat.
And this is also
laser-centered nylon.
And it's inspired by net
art and the internet.
And as you can
see, it's the grid.
So you're literally on the
grid versus off the grid.
And what's cool about
it is that because it's
like a basic, minimal pattern,
it goes with everything.
And having a background
in graphic design
at Rhode Island
School of Design,
I'm pretty used to normally,
like, seeing things on a grid,
and mapping things,
and aligning things.
So I guess my graphic
design history also--
you can see that relating
in this hat right here.
And I would say this is one
of my more popular pieces
right now.
And what's great about nylon
is that you can color-match it
to any Pantone color.
So I also have glow-in-the-dark
versions as well.
No black light needed.
And this is a special hat
collaboration with Adam Harvey,
who's a surveillance artist.
He had a full-page "New
York Times" article
about the work that
he's been doing.
And he's very
innovative in trying
to bridge the gap between
technology and art,
and where it's going.
He's done conferences
with Snowden.
And he's trying to make
aware, more and more, the fact
that we're constantly
being surveillanced
and how big brother
is watching you.
As you can see, this hat,
that's where your eyes align,
and the nose bridge-- like, you
can see all the sacred geometry
happening right now.
And it has a Buckminster
Fuller-like geodesic dome
kind of structure in the back.
And it's made, so
that it can be worn.
And it blocks face
detection in computers.
So this is a prototype.
And it first debuted at
the New Museum Demo Day
in January, this past January.
And we're going through
second and third rounds soon.
And it's been
presented in the FBI,
and there's a lot
of interest in it,
because people want to
avoid being seen by everyone
and being recognized.
So there you go.
This is the Ampersand hat.
And--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Ah.
HEIDI LEE: Oh, sorry.
It's a combination between an
at symbol and an ampersand.
And it was commissioned by
"The New Republic" magazine.
It's a political magazine.
And it was recently just
bought by a Facebook founder.
But anyways, they
commissioned me
to create any piece that
had any ampersand in it
for their Books
and the Arts page.
So I decided to show
where things are going.
Like, things are becoming
more and more digital.
And just 3D printing, too, the
marvelous aspects behind it
is the fact that you can create
something out of nothing.
And things that you could
normally not print or create
any other way are possible
through 3D printing.
And I decided to make a
combination of an ampersand
and an at symbol, and create
a whole new symbol, or emoji,
you could say.
And I'm going to also make an at
symbol hat to go with this one.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Cool.
HEIDI LEE: And this
is the Echo hat.
And I've gotten a lot
of press from this,
because it's just a showstopper,
and people are really
curious about it.
Especially at the Silicon
Valley Fashion Week,
this had the most attention,
and people were, like,
cheering really hard.
So can you demonstrate for us?
So she's going to do a 360.
And as you can see, there's
eight faces that go around.
And this is also
kind of commentary
on how we live in a
surveillance age as well,
and how we live in
the age of the selfie,
and how people are
really consumed
with the idea of Facebook.
And Facebook is there
really a book of faces.
So it all ties in, in that way.
And it's a critique
on how we live
in a society of that,
as well as it references
Greek and Roman mythology, the
story of Echo and Narcissus,
of how Echo, this woodland
nymph, yearns for Narcissus.
But Narcissus instead,
like, falls in love
with his own reflection.
So I love that
mythological story.
And they're always like-- I
felt really in tune with it
as a kid.
So I wanted to
create a piece that
was referencing that-- like
mythological, ancient story
with something modern, too,
with this new technique
in 3D printing of
laser-centered nylon, which
is high-resolution.
And you can get
really fine details
that you couldn't get otherwise.
So thank you.
And this is the
Atomic Universe hat.
And I was really
fascinated with the idea
of the Big Bang in
physics, because I never
studied that as a kid.
And I wanted to make a
visual representation
of how electrons would, like,
flow and spin around a nucleus.
So this is an actual
representation
of ladies representing
electrons, you could say.
And as you can see,
it's very trippy.
And depending on how you
permutate your head--
like how you drop
your head around--
it also those
different orbital--
AUDIENCE: Oh, nice.
HEIDI LEE: --yeah, movements.
So yeah.
See?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, if you turn
down the lights,
maybe you guys could see better.
But yeah, this is a really
fun showstopper, too.
[CHUCKLES] So yeah, those
are just some of these hats.
And this is the
letter of recognition
that I got from Harold Koda,
which I was really lucky enough
to be part of.
It was a nationwide contest
that was open to all design
students in America.
And it was in conjunction with
the Elsa Schiaparelli and Prada
exhibition on how
Schiaparelli and Prada really
felt deeply connected
to each other because
of their love of art, and
fashion, and surrealism.
So as you can see,
a lot of my hats
have homages to
surrealism happening.
And this cocktail
parasol hat-- like,
I guess you could
say I Duchamped it.
Like, just how like Marcel
Duchamp took a bicycle wheel
and put it in
different contexts,
and put it on the stool, he
created a monumental piece
of artwork.
Like, I feel like putting
an umbrella on a headband,
it's kind of similar
in the same aspects.
So I wanted to also show
you some of my other hats
that weren't able
to be here today.
So you can kind of do-- you
could see a scope of some
of my other stuff.
This is the Echo hat again.
And I also have a
mirrored version
that was chromed by the
same chromers as Jeff Koons.
And it has a very hall
of mirrors aspect to it.
And it really plays with
the double entendre of who's
watching who really, literally.
And you get to see
yourself in the mirror
as well as see other people
around you at the same time.
This is a piece that I
did for Victor Osborne.
He's also a milliner
that has done
commissioned pieces for
Tom Brown, and [INAUDIBLE],
and a few other top designers.
That's how I kind of started
off-- apprenticing under him.
And he gave me an opportunity
to make an origami hat out
of paper, but a miniature
version that was sent out
to accessory editors at "Vogue,"
"GQ," "W," "Harper's Bazaar,"
all the top editors.
And they were able to get
this mini hat box invite.
And in exchange,
they had a free hat.
So that was the interesting,
like, box of curiosities,
you could say,
that they received.
What's cool about this
is the origins of origami
like [INAUDIBLE] which
is a type of magic that's
made with paper, you can
transform these shapes
into many different shapes.
Like for example, this can
be worn three different ways.
So I was playing with the idea
of how Houdini even used to use
[INAUDIBLE].
And I wanted to
make that into a hat
and make it into an
interesting curiosity keepsake.
That's me with the few
additions that I had created.
This is the Fencing Bonnet hat.
It's made out of this material
called [? cineme. ?] And you
can mold it with your hands.
And by the heat of your hands
and spraying it with water,
you can transform the material
into different shapes.
And I also worked with my uncle,
who's also a hat designer.
And he's been in the
industry for over 30 years.
So I was able to grasp a lot
from working with him as well.
And these hats are currently
being pulled by "Vogue Italia."
Shot by Steven Meisel
for a shoot that's
coming up next month.
Again, that's the Ampersand
hat in black and white.
This is the Redrum hat.
And it's plastic that
was melted with a heat
gun in the organic shape
that you see right there.
This is the Dali hat.
It's inspired by Salvador
Dali and his "Persistence
of Memory."
And I made a special commission
version for Lady Gaga,
where it's a holographic time
hat on the right-hand side.
So I use this holographic
film to use as a base layer,
and then vinyl lettered the
Roman numerals afterwards.
This is this interesting
material called horsehair.
And what's cool about it is
that once you sew it in half,
you can pull at it,
and it starts curving,
and it becomes a swirl.
So this is called a
swirl hat on the left.
And then this is a
Cone Bra hat, which
is inspired by Jean
Paul Gaultier's corset
that Madonna wore
for "Truth or Dare."
The Cone Bra hat
was commissioned
by the Brooklyn Museum for me
to lead a 50-people class that
was like sold out.
So that was a really
great opportunity
that happened in 2014.
It was also in conjunction with
the international exhibition
retrospective of
Jean Paul Gaultier.
These are some
other colors, waves.
And in conjunction with the
small Cocktail Parasol hat,
I also had this big
Parasol Skeleton hat.
So it's a jumbo version.
And those two garner the
award for the Met Museum.
Also different color waves--
red, white, and blue.
Trying to be patriotic.
A black version.
And then different color waves
for the Cocktail Parasol hat.
The one on the right
is the Vortex hat.
Different color waves.
The one on the right here
is called A Wrinkle In Time.
And it's leather that is
embedded with these sparkles.
So I thought it, very much,
was-- I was envisioning space
and how space folds.
And what's interesting
about this hat
is that the whole
piece is folded
to make the circular,
dome-like aspect of the piece.
So it's almost
like a planetarium
of a hat or a holodeck.
If you look on the
inside, the grow grain
that surrounds the ribbon has
planetary-- like Milky Way
constellations
enwrapping your head.
This is called the Aerial hat.
And as you can see, it has
a blue-green iridescence
on the left and like a
pinkish, like sea foam,
like frushia going on.
It's a combination of a
baseball cap with a cowboy top.
So I was kind of
hacking that idea.
This is the Aerial Finn hat.
This is also the same
blue-green iridescence, too.
It's the same leather that Comme
des Garcons made their wallets
with.
It's the same iridescence.
The one on the right
is the Third Eye hat.
And they're made of real
photopolymer holograms.
About 130.
And the base of the hat, too,
is also rainbow holograms.
So it's all holographic.
This is the Singularity hat.
And as you can see, it's
like a motherboard pattern.
And it's a little,
like, old school style.
But I like the idea
of mixing old and new.
At the time, I was
reading Ray Kurzweil's
"The Singularity" book.
And I was really faced
with the concerns of what
singularity might look like.
So the idea of biological and
technological coming together,
and the idea of a
lenticular having two sides,
of a double-edged sword,
like, being the same thing.
I thought that was really
fitting to make these hats.
Yeah.
As you can see, that's
the Atomic Universe hat
on the left, and then
the Body Electric hat.
And it's inspired
by Walt Whitman's "I
Sing the Body Electric" poem.
If you have a chance, I highly
recommend you guys reading it.
It's a wonderful poem.
And it's made with
addressable LEDs
that all kind of speak
the same language
of this rainbow, melting
colors that are happening.
And it was featured in a show
studio punk film last year.
And it featured
[INAUDIBLE], a supermodel
who is now the face of L'Oreal.
This is the Glass hat.
And it's inspired
by coral reefs.
And it's a piece
of antique glass
that I re-appropriated and
created into a hat piece.
This is the Cocktail
Parasol hat in red.
But it's amazing to see
my stuff actually used
in editorials and stuff.
It was like, that's the very
fulfilling part about doing
this-- seeing it in a
whole different context
from different eyes and
different artistic directors.
So this is a few of my
press that I've gotten.
End of Century.
There was a show
called "Gallery Girls"
that featured my hats
on television for Bravo.
This is the Redrum hat.
And "redrum" is "murder"
spelled backwards.
So I liked the idea
of how it looked
like blood that was
coagulating and becoming
this mass of cells.
So yeah.
The Parasol Skeleton Hat,
the year that I created it,
garnered a lot of attention.
It was in "The New York Times."
And the next day after
this on the left,
it was featured in Bill
Cunningham's Sunday Style page.
And as you can see,
the girl on the right,
she's wearing a
Mini Origami hat.
The hat on the left is
called the Carnal Floral hat.
And it's made of plastic flowers
that were all pieced together
kind of like ikebani.
I forget the exact word
of how you arrange flowers
in Japanese flower arrangements.
I think it's called ikebana.
But anyways, yeah, that
was the inspiration--
to make something really out
of this world and bizarre,
almost taxidermied, but
in a plant-like way.
And the picture on the right--
I was featured in "W" magazine.
And I'm wearing the
Melting Clock hat.
These are special hats
that I created that have
LEDs where the eyes are.
[LAUGHTER]
And then this isn't a
very-- Michelle Harper,
she's like a fashion muse.
I had the great
privilege of her wearing
my hat for an editorial.
So yeah, these are
some other hats.
Do you guys have any questions?
Or want to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HEIDI LEE: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Question here.
AUDIENCE: So I've actually--
I've been following you
for a long time.
I'm a big fan.
HEIDI LEE: Oh, really?
AUDIENCE: Um, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
I was wondering if you were
ever going to do any clothing,
or if you're just going
to stick with hats?
HEIDI LEE: I want to
be known for hats first
and then slowly enter
other realms, too.
In fashion, clothing is
a natural progression.
So definitely keep your
eyes peeled for me.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
HEIDI LEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
for-- thanks for coming.
The stuff's beautiful.
HEIDI LEE: Thanks
for being here.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess my question--
I have a two-part question.
So like, why did
you start with hats,
and why was that your
beginning fashion piece,
and why is that your
staple of your work?
HEIDI LEE: OK.
I could say hats, in a lot of
ways-- you could see them--
as a child at least, it
was a bit of comfort,
like a pillow or a
security blanket.
It gives you a sense of
belonging to something.
And no matter what
context you're in,
you can still have
your own thinking space
and your own-- bring to the
table a piece of yourself.
So that's what I like about it.
So no matter what
matrix you're in,
you're still in
your own head space.
So that's what I
like about hats.
And you know, wearing
a hat, your mind
is connected to it as well.
So it's interconnected.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And the second part
of the question
was, it looks like
fashion's going pretty
digital these days, right?
So do you see that
becoming a bigger trend?
And then what's the
future of digital LEDs,
and lighting, and
movement within fashion?
HEIDI LEE: Yeah.
I believe in the idea of the
new aesthetic, that coined term,
where the digital is becoming
more and more physical.
So as you can see,
3D printing, it
starts with a vector
file and a file
that becomes something real.
So yeah, your imagination
is the limits.
Anything can happen, really,
when you put your imagination
into reality.
And 3D printing is the medium.
AUDIENCE: It seems
3D printing and body
scanning are these fantastic
tools for creating really
personalized pieces,
which is something,
I guess, in like the
modern, commoditized world,
that things are made
for millions of people
to be as cheap as possible.
But what do you think it would
take before the 3D printing
and body scanning can
actually be used at, like,
a large scale?
HEIDI LEE: I think that
there's a lot of patents that
are expiring hopefully soon.
So it'll become more and more
affordable for normal people
to wear and have access to.
As you can see, there's already
places like Kinko's and stuff
that have 3D printers.
And I can see over there,
right there, like a MakerBot.
And that's a little bit
more low-resolution,
like plastic extrusion.
But there's going to be more
and more options coming out
in the market as competition
makes things more affordable.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could talk a bit more
about the process.
Like, you started talking a bit
about the different resolutions
of 3D printing or whatever.
But like, say if someone
wanted to try out
nylon printing or something,
like how you might go about it.
HEIDI LEE: Well, this
is nylon printing.
So it starts off
in a bed of powder.
And your file, once you
put it in, layer by layer,
the lasers go through and center
the nylon, which is melting it.
So afterwards, after
they print it all,
they dust off all the powder.
And what remains is kind of
like an archeological dig.
You find this piece,
and it's ready to go.
AUDIENCE: Do you
feel like the process
is any different for a
fashion sort of-- these kinds
of statements that you are
doing versus other stuff
that people are making?
HEIDI LEE: Well, I
think the way to go
if you're doing high
fashion is flexible nylon,
3D-printed stuff, because it's
the most wearable out there,
I would say.
And yeah, also, it's
extremely high-resolution.
The low-resolution stuff,
you can see the lines,
and you can see little
strings coming out and stuff.
You can see the quality.
It's obvious, because
the printer costs, like,
half a million dollars, the
ones that you see here today.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about how you got started,
and what type of work you
did before you went to RISD,
and how many of these
pieces were made
while you were a student there?
HEIDI LEE: Initially,
when I moved to New York,
I was working for
a multimillionaire,
a luxury real estate marketing
company called [INAUDIBLE].
And we would kind of
dream up crazy ideas
of creating artificial
islands in Dubai,
and imagining what the
resort would look like,
and how the spas would be
underwater, and such like that.
So it was pretty
intense and interesting
working with buildings that
Philippe Starck designed
and Jade Jagger, to
name a few, in W Hotels.
But at the end of
the day, I felt
like I wanted to do something
more fulfilling and more
personal, and wanted to share
my stories through these hats,
as you can see.
And initially, I
didn't really know
I was going to get
into hat design.
I just kind of stumbled upon it.
And it started off apprenticing
under Victor Osborne,
the milliner.
And then I started just
creating my hats little
by little over that time period,
starting with the origami hats,
and then creating more
functional pieces.
And I feel like my stuff tries
to bridge the gap between art,
and fashion, and design
all at the same time.
So each of my hats,
you could say,
are statement pieces,
because each of them
have strong concepts
behind them.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: On average,
how long does it
tend to take you, with your
entire creative process--
from the ideas,
sketching it out--
I don't know what other
steps are in there-- and then
actually, like, OK,
hat's 3D-printed?
HEIDI LEE: I could
say, coming from RISD,
they train you to have
a really sharp eye.
And also, it doesn't help that
I'm a bit of a perfectionist.
So it takes me lots and
lots of rounds and revisions
to get to the level
that you see here today.
So it's like trial and error.
And if it doesn't fit, you
try again and again and again.
And then you hone it.
And it becomes an
actual, sellable product.
So that's one way,
as you can see.
AUDIENCE: Is that
like months or--
HEIDI LEE: Every hat
has its own process.
Some hats-- like just
like making a hit song.
You never know.
It could take a couple days,
or it could take a month
or like-- it has its own
wavelength of process,
I could say.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering, what
sort of constraints
do you give yourself when you're
thinking about a new design?
HEIDI LEE: It
definitely is something
that is palpable for people,
but then still striking.
Like, I want to make
something that is something
that a consumer would
want in general,
and maybe satiate the
masses in that sense,
but then also have the
integrity of ergonomics,
like design and function.
AUDIENCE: As you can
see, in this space,
The Garage here is kind
of like a scrappy place
that we use to prototype
and brainstorm.
I was wondering how you
deal with a space like this
or what's in your
creative process?
Do you have a specific space
where you ideate this stuff?
HEIDI LEE: I feel, to be honest,
at ease in this kind of space,
like a working space, because
making some of my hats--
for example, the
Echo hat, it took
a lot of priming, and sanding,
and priming-- like days
and days of doing that.
And it would be in a
workspace like this, where
I would actually do it myself.
Right now, I don't have, at
my leisure, many interns.
So I do most of the work myself.
So as you can see,
getting it to that point,
it was a lot of
my own hand labor.
So being in a real raw, like
hands-on space like this,
that's where I feel at
ease and comfortable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Back to you.
HEIDI LEE: Cool.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Sweet.
HEIDI LEE: Yeah.